القوه الامنيه اعتصام نفذه عسكريون
متقاعدون وناشطون مدنيون في محيط مقر
البرلمان والسرايا الحكومي بوسط العاصمه
اللبنانيه بيروت احتجاجا على ترد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه وقد استخدمت القوى
الامنيه القنابل المسيله للدموع لابعاد
المتظاهرين بعدما حاولوا اجتياز الاسلاك
الشائكه الموضوعه في المكان وحمل
المشاركون الذين اعتصموا امام مقر
البرلمان السلطه السياسيه والمصرف المركزي
المسؤوليه ما وصلت اليه البلاد من ازمات
وانهيار على مختلف الاصعده وطلب المحتجون
بزياده الرواتب بما يتناسب مع ارتفاع
اسعار السلع وانهيار قيمه العمله الوطنيه
كما ادعوا الى زياده التقديمات الطبيه
والمنح التعليميه والمساعدات الاجتماعيه
للموظفين
ونتابع اذا هذه الصور المباشره لهذه
المظاهره كما ذكرنا العسكريين المتقاعدين
ايضا حركه الانقاذ الوطني كما علمنا في
ساحه رياض الصلح تاتي المظاهر احتجاجا اذا
على تردي الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
وسيوفينا بمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه
المظاهره والجهات المنظمه لها الزميل
مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي كلمه اليكها
نعم ربما الصوره خلفي تشهد على هذا
الاضطراب في الشارع اللبناني الذي تجدد
امام السرايا الحكومي بسبب تردي الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه في لبنان القوى الامنيه امطرت
المعتصمين ومعظمهم من القوى الامنيه
المتقاعدون في القوى الامنيه والجيش
بوابل من
القنابل الموسيه للدموع والرد برشق القوى
الامنيه بالحجاره وحاولوا اقتحام السياج
الذي كانت وضعته القوى الامنيه في مقابل
السرايا الحكومي ومقر رئاسه الحكومه ربما
نشاهد في الصوره الجيش اللبناني الذي
انتشر عناصره في هذا المكان وايضا ربما في
الخلفيه الصوره القوى الامنيه التي كانت
تطلق
الغاز المثير للدموع باتجاه المعتصمين في
هذا المكان وفق ما شاهدنا اداء ادت
الغازات المسيله للدموع الى
حالات اختناق بين المتظاهرين الذين نقل
بعضهم باتجاه مراكز الاسعاف القريبه من
هذا المكان يحاول هؤلاء التجمع مجددا في
هذه المنطقه التي لا زالت تشهد نوع من
الاحتكاك بين القوى الامنيه والمتظرين
يطالب هؤلاء
بمعالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والماليه
ويعترضون عليها ويعتبرون ان ما يجري من
انهيار لقيمه الليره اللبنانيه امام
الدولار ادى الى تاكل رواتبهم بشكل كبير
وايضا الى عدم قدرتهم على ايفاء حاجاتهم
الاساسيه من غذاء ودواء لعائلاتهم بسبب
هذا الانهيار
العسكريون المتقاعدون يشاركهم ايضا
مجموعات مختلفه مما يعرف باسم الحراك
الشعبي في عدد من المناطق اللبنانيه الذين
توجهوا الى ساحه رياض الصلح وهي وسط
العاصمه ربما نشاهد في الصوره خلفيه بخلف
خلفياتها ايضا المئات منهم الذين تر الى
الخلف بسبب وابل القنابل المثيره لدموع
التي اطلقتها القوى الامنيه على عده دفعات
باتجاههم البرلمان اللبناني ايضا قريب من
هذا المكان يبعد عشرات الامطار وفي
الخلفيه السرايا الحكومي اللبناني الذي هو
مقرئاسه الحكومه اللبنانيه عمليا لبنان
يعمل بحكومه تصريف اعمال
هناك شهور في سده رئاسه الجمهوريه ليس لدى
لبنان رئيسا للجمهوريه والبرلمان اللبناني
اخفق منذ ايلول سبتمبر الماضي في انتخاب
رئيس جديد لجمهوريه يكون مقدمه
لحل الوضع السياسي الذي يؤثر ايضا على
الوضع الاقتصادي والمالي في البلاد لذلك
تعد هذه المظاهره ربما الاولى بعد انقطاع
دام اشهر من الشارع من قبل مجموعات مختلفه
ومن قبل جمعيات والمؤسسات وايضا الان بدا
مشددا اطلاق القنابل المثيره للدموع
باتجاهنا وباتجاه هذه المنطقه تحديدا حيث
نقف تحاول القوه الامنيه
ردعه هؤلاء من التقدم باتجاه رئاسه
الحكومه مجددا وعدم اشغال القوه الامنيه
في مناطق اخرى من خلال اطلاق الغازات
المثيره للدموع حاليا هناك المئات من
العناصر الامنيه المتواجده في محيط رئاسه
الحكومه وفي ايضا محيط البرلمان ويمكن
مشاهده ايضا الجيش اللبناني الذي يتمركز
خلفه الشريط الشائك والذي يحمي هذا الشارع
المؤدي الى البرلمان اللبناني طبعا تجهز
الجيش الشعبي وقيات من الغاز وايضا القوى
الامنيه في المقابل الاخر تحاول الان ردعه
المتقاعدين وايضا المجموعات الاخرى من
تسلق المنطقه باتجاه السراي الحكومي
شكرا لك ايهاب